[Music]
live in the class on mm3 drink the wild
air
Ralph Waldo my new hashtag Rosco stop
your science logic and reason and
counseling baby you're a firework
American flag emoji you're so cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's your biggest emotional wound what
their question of the day ah mine's
actually my relationship with my dad I'm
good thanks
alright well in that case welcome to
grateful kitchen my name is Eden how can
I nourish you today you know I'm
actually meeting a friend for lunch here
have you seen her oh yeah
Taylor Sloane yeah yeah she comes in all
the time I know she was actually here
like an hour ago you said you're meeting
her for lunch oh god I must have found a
time wrong so stupid do you remember
what she ordered
[Music]
I'll give one of you 200 bucks if you
punch me in the face not fine if you
person can't handle on [ __ ]
congratulations la is the best I'm
making a ton of new friends okay
hi I'm Taylor can you read before no you
do this a lot
not anymore okay you need to relax it's
just described you can buff that right
out this is my brother Nick I yeah what
is I don't like these people
Nicky where's my phone killers favorite
brunch spot is the facial for sleeping
so they're just a joke
you [ __ ] everybody yet we need to be
smart we little guilders do right no
we're just gonna scare him a lot of X in
Park Sena be days like this
I'm not a psychopath I just want to be
her friend you've been dating a week
news are you letting you borrow a truck
I just gave him a [ __ ] damn girl you
move fast every bloody kid how do you
about truth it was an accident okay
anything else I need to know about
English he might have done all of your
company that we found in there thank you
guys thank you for your service
[Applause]
you